here with reaction former white house
chief of staff reince priebus fox news
contributor charlie hurt reince let's
get your reaction this is all they have
there's nothing positive they can run on
not a single thing
now the question is will this strategy
of slander smear
besmirchment character assassination
will that work
i don't think it's going to work at all
because i do think that the american
people see that our economy is in the
tank and gas is up the border's not
secure but this is what they've got and
they have decided that since they have
nothing they've got ridicule and as
olinsky i've been
following this thing for since
since obama alinsky has always when he
wrote his rules for radicals he said
that ridicule is man's best weapon and
that's what they're doing they are
targeting people they are polarizing
people they're personalizing it and
they're going after republicans with
these insane
attacks and when you talk about fascism
put aside the fascism of joe biden
through executive order shutting
keystone pipeline shutting down the
market doing all the things he's done
when you talk about purging
a party of disease that sounds like
fascist language uh to me and you have
these candidates out there you talk
about fascism mandela barnes in
wisconsin run against ron johnson's
talking about releasing 50
of the state's prisoners
fetterman
your buddy in pennsylvania uh
sean is talking about releasing 30
percent of the state's prisoners it
doesn't get any more wild than that and
finally when joe biden comes to
wisconsin and pennsylvania as as nuts as
that platform sounds those two
candidates didn't want to go by joe
biden you know why because he's
unpopular the economy is in the tank and
people know it now charlie if this
election becomes about record high
inflation record high gas prices record
high prices for everything you buy in
every store you go to if it becomes
about law and order and safety and
security if it's about education of our
kids if it's about all of these things
and not about the ad hominem attacks and
the name calling and the demonization
of any conservative or republican i say
republicans win if that's what they run
on
now the question is which side is going
to win the narrative
yeah no i think you're exactly right
about that and i think that is exactly
why
you have democrats uh maligning and
insulting half of the country every time
they talk
and of course there's nothing in the
world that's more fascist than having a
president calling half of the people he
works for fascist or semi-fascist or
having uh the former first lady talk
about how uh
our voters in this country her political
opponents who don't support her are
somehow a disease in this country this
is really sick language this kind of
effort to dehumanize people is what
fascists do so the only fascists here
are hillary clinton and joe biden but
you're exactly right they have
absolutely nothing to run on they
control every lever of power in
washington both chambers of congress and
the white house they can they could run
the tables they could do whatever they
want and and what they have done so far
has been to destroy the country and
you've gone through all of those
important things whether it's
skyrocketing crime gas prices inflation
open border misery around the world
terrorism taking a new route in in
places like afghanistan so they have
nothing else to run on but i think
you're exactly right sean i think you
know these things people it's not just
conservatives and republicans who want
their families to be safe or want to be
able to afford gasoline democrat voters
want that too and as long as republicans
remain laser focused on that and talk
about the ideas that we all spot
you know believe in and that donald
trump talked about
then republicans are going to walk away
with this thing in two years and
republicans are going to walk away even
bigger uh uh
or you know next month they're going to
walk away with it and then walk away
even bigger i think in two years all
right so reince you had great success as
the rnc chair what do you tell people
running for the house running for the
senate my understanding is next week
that kevin mccarthy will lay out his
version of a contract with america
commitments to america i like that idea
i like the idea that every candidate
signs their name and makes a pledge to
do
certain things before they run i would
like the senate candidate candidates to
do the same
what do republicans need to do to keep
the focus where it belongs
well i i agree with you too i i think
number one you got to tell people what
you're for i think a contract with
america or a new contract whatever he's
going to call it is brilliant number one
number two you cannot let these
candidates like mandela barnes and
fetterman and these folks get away with
portraying themselves as something that
they're not they're on tv every minute
telling people that their mainstream
while at the same time they're talking
about releasing prisoners they're
talking about defunding the police and
they're on the record talking about
cashless bail that people who commit
violent crimes should not have to pay a
cash bail in order to get out of prison
this is what the record is so i think
republicans have to be relentless in
what they're for relentless on pointing
out what their opponent is for and then
they need to tell their own story about
their own lives and their own families
and and their own sacrifices i think all
of that together is important last thing
you got to focus on the ground game and
the grass roots you got to focus on
absentee ballot request forms targeting
people turning out voters and just
obviously like lincoln said you know
have more ballots in the box than the
other guy do you feel the republican
party has that technology are they
prepared to compete
uh with the democrats on that level in
terms of getting out the vote yeah
i i i do sean and i think that we've
also learned a lesson about uh voting
and election integrity and not waiting
until after the election to do something
about it and i think that's one of the
things that's changed over the last
couple years charlie will give you the
last word
yeah the most important thing they have
to focus on
personal security crime and the economy
and the border and if republicans focus
on those three things and hit these
people as hard as they can about the
fact that they have been for open
borders no bail lawlessness they've
supported the riots for two years you as
long as republicans stay on that i think
that they're gonna have a good day in
november all right charlie thank you
reince thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else